Hey there, it's This American Life. We first aired today's program in 2013. But we're going to air it again right now. Because just this week, after many, many years, there's news. Story's changed.
大家好，这是《This American Life》。我们今天重播的节目首播于2013年。但我们现在打算再播一次，因为就在本周，时隔多年后，有了新的消息，故事发生了变化。
So what we've going to do this hour is play the original story, then we have an update for you towards the end.
所以我们这一小时要做的就是播放最初的故事，然后在结尾处为大家带来最新的进展。
As you'll hear, the reporter is Sarah Koenig, host of Serial. She did this before Serial, but you'll hear she's in here solving a mystery in a very Serial-like way.
正如你们将听到的，这位记者是《Serial》的主持人莎拉·柯尼格（Sarah Koenig）。她在做《Serial》之前就完成了这个故事，但在节目中你们会听到她正以一种非常“Serial”的方式解开一个谜团。
Anyway, here's the original story.
总之，这就是最初的故事。
Benjamin Gilmer was finishing his training to be a doctor and he was applying for jobs. And there was this one job that he was really excited about at a small rural clinic in North Carolina, a place called Cane Creek, about 15 miles outside of Asheville. But there were two slightly strange things about this job.
本杰明·吉尔默（Benjamin Gilmer）当时快要完成医生培训，正在申请工作。他对北卡罗来纳州一个叫甘蔗溪（Cane Creek）的偏远小诊所的一份工作非常兴奋，距离阿什维尔（Asheville）大约15英里。但这份工作有两件略显奇怪的事。
The first was that his predecessor at the position-- who was the guy who started the clinic-- had left the job after murdering his own father, strangling him and sawing off his fingers. And the other strange thing?
第一件是他的前任——也就是创办这家诊所的人——在谋杀了亲生父亲后离开了岗位，他勒死了父亲并锯掉了他的手指。那么另一件奇怪的事是什么呢？
At first I didn't make the connection that his name was the same as mine.
起初我没把他的名字和我的联系在一起。
This is Benjamin Gilmer.
这是本杰明·吉尔默。
And then during my interview, they reminded me, well, his name was actually Dr. Gilmer.
后来在面试时他们提醒我，他的名字其实也是吉尔默医生。
That's right. The murderer was Dr. Vince Gilmer. He was Dr. Benjamin Gilmer, no relation at all.
没错。那位杀人犯是文斯·吉尔默（Vince Gilmer）医生。他是本杰明·吉尔默医生，两人完全没有关系。
And there was concern from the boards my presence out there might potentially even be harmful, because I share the same name. You know, whether some patients would just elect not to come. I mean, there was confusion.
董事会很担心我在那里的存在可能会产生负面影响，因为我们名字相同。你知道，有些病人可能会选择不来看病。我的意思是，这造成了困惑。
People think it's strange, just very-- it's very strange.
人们觉得这很奇怪，真的——非常奇怪。
This is Robin Whiteside, who works at the clinic. Benjamin Gilmer must be a very qualified young man, because they did give him the job. And sure enough, it did cause confusion among the patients, freaked a few out.
这是在该诊所工作的罗宾·怀特塞德（Robin Whiteside）。本杰明·吉尔默肯定是一位非常有资历的年轻人，因为他们确实录用了他。果不其然，这确实在病人中引起了困惑，吓坏了一些人。
A patient called. I said, I can schedule you with Dr. Gilmer.
一位病人打电话来。我说，我可以为您预约吉尔默医生。
Terry Ippilito sits at the front desk of the clinic.
特里·伊皮利托（Terry Ippilito）坐在诊所的前台。
And they said, is this a-- it was near Halloween. And they said, is this a Halloween joke?
他们说，这是——当时接近万圣节。他们说，这是万圣节的玩笑吗？
As if there is such a thing as a Halloween joke. Anyway, one patient, Benjamin was meeting her for the very first time. He walks into the exam room.
仿佛真有万圣节玩笑这回事似的。总之，有一位病人，本杰明是第一次见她。他走进诊室。
And she literally was having a panic attack.
她真的在惊恐发作。
Hyperventilating, heart palpitations. She thought maybe the other Dr. Gilmer, the murderer, was going to be seeing her. But as Benjamin settled in at the clinic and people got to know him, something interesting happened. Many of Vince's former patients, who were now Benjamin's patients, started talking to him about Vince.
过度换气，心悸。她以为可能是另一位吉尔默医生，那个杀人犯要来看她。但随着本杰明在诊所安定下来，人们开始了解他，有趣的事情发生了。许多文斯以前的病人，现在成了本杰明的病人，开始向他谈论文斯。
Each one of them felt like they needed to say something to clear the-- clear the air, I suppose. But they wanted me to know who he was, who was absolutely not what the papers were describing or just an ax murderer. Which was the thought that I had going into this job was that I'm following the footsteps of an ax murderer. But that's not the story that increasingly was being described by his patients.
他们每个人都觉得需要说点什么来澄清——澄清事实吧，我想。但他们想让我知道他是谁，他绝不是报纸上描述的那样，或者仅仅是一个斧头杀手。这也是我在接手这份工作前的想法，认为我是在追随一个斧头杀手的脚步。但病人们描述的故事却越来越不是那样。
For instance, Ruth Tracy. When she first came to Vince for treatment, she had just lost her job. Her husband wasn't working either. No insurance. She told Vince, don't do tests. I can't afford it. Vince wouldn't hear of it.
例如，鲁思·特雷西（Ruth Tracy）。她第一次去找文斯治疗时，刚失业。她丈夫也没工作。没有保险。她告诉文斯，别做检查了。我负担不起。文斯根本不听。
And he did not charge me for my appointments for almost six months. He gave me my medication out of samples. And he listened to me. I could cry on his shoulder. He would give me a hug. I mean, he always made me feel better. I'd say, how can you treat me like this and not collect money? And he said, we have to help each other out.
他有近六个月没收我的诊费。他把药物样本给我。他倾听我说话。我可以在他肩上哭泣。他会拥抱我。我的意思是，他总是让我感觉好些。我说，你怎么能这样对待我却不收钱？他说，我们要互相帮助。
This is not an exceptional story about Vince Gilmer. Lots of people would tell you what a great guy he was. Generous to a fault, he'd help you pay to get your car repaired, buy you a present for no reason. If you had no money, he would take a bushel of corn as payment. He was a big, burly man. His nickname was Bear. He hugged everybody.
这不是文斯·吉尔默的个例。很多人会告诉你他是个多么棒的人。慷慨到极致，他会帮你修车，无缘无故给你买礼物。如果你没钱，他会收一蒲式耳玉米当报酬。他是个身材魁梧的壮汉。他的绰号叫“熊”。他拥抱每个人。
He was a solid guy, a gentle guy. He gave free annual checkups to the local firefighters. He made house calls. House calls! Didn't charge for them. And when one of our producers, Sarah Koenig, went around asking about Vince, she heard that some people still had a hard time believing that Vince would be capable of cold-blooded murder, even though he's serving in prison for it-- like Jerol Davis, one of his former patients. He told Sarah it made no sense.
他是个踏实的人，温柔的人。他为当地消防员提供免费的年度体检。他进行家庭出诊。家庭出诊！而且不收费。当我们的制作人之一莎拉·柯尼格四处打听文斯时，她听说有些人仍然很难相信文斯会做出冷血谋杀，尽管他正在为此服刑——比如他以前的病人杰罗尔·戴维斯（Jerol Davis）。他告诉莎拉，这完全说不通。
And thinking back, see, his father had Alzheimer's. And I wondered if he didn't kinda consider it a mercy killing.
回想起来，看，他父亲患有阿尔茨海默病。我当时想他是否在某种程度上把它视为一种慈悲杀戮。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
To get his father out of his misery. That's the only answer I could think of.
为了让他父亲解脱苦难。这是我能想到的唯一答案。
If it was a mercy killing, doesn't it seem strange that he would strangle him? Because if he's a doctor, he would have access to whatever drugs you would need to--
如果是慈悲杀戮，他不觉得勒死他很奇怪吗？因为如果他是医生，他应该能接触到任何需要的药物来……
I didn't say he strangled him. I have no idea how he died.
我没说他勒死了他。我不知道他是怎么死的。
Oh, he strangled him.
哦，他勒死了他。
Oh? I didn't know that.
哦？我不知道。
You didn't?
你不知道？
No. I didn't know how he killed him. I did not.
不知道。我不知道他是怎么杀了他的。真的不知道。
Does it-- does that make you think differently about maybe why he did it, knowing that he strangled him?
那——知道他是勒死了他，这会让你对他的动机有不同的想法吗？
Well, not necessarily.
嗯，未必。
So Benjamin's doing this job. And, like, every few weeks, somebody is telling him some glowing story about Vince.
所以本杰明做着这份工作。而且，每隔几周，就会有人向他讲述关于文斯的一些光辉事迹。
I don't know. I don't know why I started identifying with him, but I couldn't help myself. I mean, I feel like I'm sort of a continuation of him, which I didn't expect to experience at all.
我不知道。我不知道为什么我开始认同他，但我无法控制自己。我的意思是，我觉得自己某种程度上是他的延续，这我完全没预料到。
He and Vince Gilmer had the same specialty, same job, same clinic, same last name. They were even the same age. Vince Gilmer was 41 when he murdered his father, the same age as Benjamin when he came to work at the clinic. And at some point-- and maybe you see where this is going-- Dr. Benjamin Gilmer started to get very curious about the murder that Dr. Vincent Gilmer committed.
他和文斯·吉尔默有相同的专业、相同的工作、相同的诊所、相同的姓氏。他们甚至年龄都一样。文斯·吉尔默谋杀父亲时41岁，和本杰明到诊所工作时同岁。在某个时刻——也许你已经看出事态的发展——本杰明·吉尔默医生开始对文森特·吉尔默医生犯下的谋杀案感到非常好奇。
He began asking questions, poking around, talking to people. He developed his own theories, theories to explain the murder that had never come up at Vince's trial. He gets pulled in deeper and deeper. And by the end-- and I don't think this is a spoiler alert-- things are very, very different from the way they look here at the beginning of the story. It is an amazing story. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
他开始问问题、四处打听、与人交谈。他形成了自己的理论，那些在文斯的审判中从未提及的解释谋杀案的理论。他陷得越来越深。到最后——我不认为这是剧透——事情与故事开头看起来的样子非常、非常不同。这是一个令人惊叹的故事。来自WBEZ芝加哥，这是《This American Life》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。
And with that, I will pass things off to Sarah Koenig, who's the one who went to North Carolina and watched this all unfold. Here's Sarah.
说到这里，我把话筒交给莎拉·柯尼格，她亲自去了北卡罗来纳州，目睹了这一切的展开。这是莎拉。
When Benjamin first told me that he identified with Vince Gilmer, felt connected to him, I didn't really get it until I went there to the Cane Creek Clinic and hung around and watched Benjamin with his patients. What I hadn't understood is that Benjamin is the same kind of doctor Vince was.
当本杰明第一次告诉我他认同文斯·吉尔默，感到与他有联系时，我并没有真正理解，直到我去甘蔗溪诊所闲逛，观察本杰明对待病人的方式。我之前没理解的是，本杰明和文斯是同一种医生。
I don't know how else to say this, but he cares about his patients, really cares. And they can tell, so they confess things. The morning I spent there, a pregnant woman told him she did not want the baby's grandfather at the hospital when she gave birth. And so, they crafted a plan for how to keep him at bay.
我不知道该怎么说，但他关心他的病人，真的关心。他们能感觉得到，所以他们会坦白一些事情。我待在那里的那天早上，一位孕妇告诉他，她分娩时不想让宝宝的祖父在医院。于是，他们制定了一个计划来阻止他。
A young mother of two said she'd just left her husband, which is better for everyone, even though she now had to work all the time and put her kids in daycare. You are doing good work with your children, Benjamin told her. And she almost started to cry. There was an older patient, who came in anxious about a lump in her groin that Benjamin had already assured her was benign. He gives her a sonogram.
一位年轻的二胎妈妈说她刚离开丈夫，这对比每个人都好，尽管她现在必须不停工作并把孩子送去托儿所。你把孩子照顾得很好，本杰明告诉她。她差点哭出来。还有一位年长的病人，她很担心腹股沟的一个肿块，本杰明已经向她保证那是良性的。他给她做了超声波检查。
So see? See that black area?
看到了吗？看到那片黑色区域了吗？
I do.
看到了。
That black area is fluid.
那片黑色区域是液体。
OK.
好的。
It's not a solid mass. Masses-- for example, like cancer-- are solid and become white. So that's black, which we call anechoic. So that means--
它不是固体肿块。肿块——例如癌症——是实心的，会变成白色。那是黑色的，我们称之为无回声。所以这意味着——
She does not need the sonogram. And he will not charge her for the sonogram. But he knows it's the one thing that's going to make her feel better, if she can just visualize this harmless thing. And it works. By the end of the appointment, she's laughing.
她其实不需要这个超声波。他也不会收她超声波检查的钱。但他知道，如果她能亲眼看到这个无害的东西，这会让她感觉好点。这奏效了。预约结束时，她在笑。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
This doctor-patient trust, it's so intimate in a little practice like this one. And now, Benjamin Gilmer and Vince Gilmer know some of the same intimate things about the same people. And that's why Benjamin started to feel connected to Vince. And then one day, last fall, one of Vince's former patients said something that rattled Benjamin. It was an older man.
这种医患信任，在这样的小诊所里是如此亲密。现在，本杰明·吉尔默和文斯·吉尔默对同一些人了解一些相同的私密信息。这就是为什么本杰明开始感到与文斯有联系。然后有一天，去年秋天，一位文斯以前的病人说了一些让本杰明感到不安的话。那是一位老人。
He just caught me in the hall and said, hey, you know that Dr. Gilmer knows you're here? He knows-- he knows you're practicing. You know that, don't you? And at that moment, I had-- I really had never thought about that, that of course he knows exactly what my name was, where I live, and that I'm working in his home.
他在走廊拦住我，说，嘿，你知道吉尔默医生知道你在这里吗？他知道——他知道你在行医。你知道这个，对吧？在那一刻，我真的从未想过，他当然确切地知道我的名字，我住在哪里，我在他的家里工作。
You know, this clinic was his baby. He built it. He dedicated his life to it. And my sort of neurosis was that I had taken over his life in a way that felt very new and strange.
你知道，这家诊所是他的心血。他建立的它。他为它贡献了毕生精力。我的某种神经质是，我以一种非常新鲜和奇怪的方式接管了他的生活。
The thought of being this close to a murderer, he said, was terrifying. And Benjamin started to cook up irrational fears. He couldn't help it. He worried Vince would get out of prison and come after him in some way. At one point, a patient mentioned that Vince was, in fact, out on parole. It turned out not to be true, but for weeks afterward, Benjamin was on alert, scanning the outside of the building when he arrived.
他说，这种与杀人犯如此亲近的想法是可怕的。本杰明开始产生不理智的恐惧。他无法控制。他担心文斯会出狱并以某种方式找上他。有一次，一位病人提到文斯实际上已经假释出狱了。事实证明这不是真的，但在接下来的几周里，本杰明一直处于警惕状态，抵达时会扫描建筑物的外部。
I come in right after him. And, you know, he would be, like, looking at the door, who's coming in and stuff.
我紧随他之后进来。你知道，他会盯着门，看谁进来之类的。
This is Laura Lira Hernandez, medical assistant at the clinic.
这是劳拉·利拉·埃尔南德斯（Laura Lira Hernandez），诊所的医疗助理。
And so, for like a week, we're in panic mode, thinking that somebody-- that he was going to show up here. He was telling me-- Dr. Gilmer was telling me that he was having nightmares and stuff.
所以，有大约一周时间，我们处于恐慌模式，以为有人——他会出现在这里。他告诉我——吉尔默医生告诉我他一直做噩梦之类的事。
You were? You were having nightmares?
是吗？你一直做噩梦？
For a few days after that, that came out.
那件事传出来后的几天里。
When I met Benjamin, this is where he stood, confused about the two versions of Vince Gilmer coexisting in his head, the murderer and the good doctor.
当我见到本杰明时，他站在那里，对自己脑海中并存的两个文斯·吉尔默的形象感到困惑：杀人犯和好医生。
I mean, he obviously was crazy when he did this act. Didn't sound like it was an intentional thing, that he was a premeditated, as I understand it. This is the trouble. Like, I'm still confused by whether he was good or not.
我的意思是，他做这件事时显然疯了。听起来不像是有意为之，据我了解不是蓄意谋杀。这就是麻烦所在。比如，我仍然很困惑他到底是好人还是坏人。
You know, it's kind of like living with a ghost in your house. And you tell your kids it's a friendly ghost, but you never know where the ghost is coming from. So I'm planning to spend my professional life in that building. It's not going to go away. And until I know more, I'm not going to be able to let it go.
你知道，这有点像在家里住着一个幽灵。你告诉孩子们那是个友好的幽灵，但你永远不知道幽灵会从哪里冒出来。我打算在那个建筑里度过我的职业生涯。它是不会消失的。而在我了解更多之前，我是无法释怀的。
Benjamin needed to sort out this mystery of how a beloved family doctor with no criminal history suddenly ups and strangles his own dad, how a good man seems to turn into a bad man.
本杰明需要解决这个谜团：一位备受爱戴且没有犯罪前科的家庭医生，是如何突然起身勒死自己父亲的，一个好人是如何似乎变成了坏人的。
So you've never seen a picture of him before?
所以你从来没见过他的照片？
I've never seen a picture. The only thing I've heard from a couple of patients is I kind of look like him.
我从来没见过照片。我从几位病人那里听到的唯一一件事就是我长得有点像他。
He started with Terry Worley. She was office manager at the Cane Creek Clinic, and good friends with Vince and his wife, Karen, who was also a physician. They'd started the clinic together and worked together. Vince and Karen didn't have kids of their own, but Vince would come to Terry's kids' basketball games. She said he was like part of their family.
他从特里·沃利（Terry Worley）开始了解。她是甘蔗溪诊所的办公室经理，和文斯以及他妻子凯伦（Karen，也是一名医生）是好朋友。他们一起创办了诊所并一起工作。文斯和凯伦没有自己的孩子，但文斯会去特里的孩子们的篮球比赛。她说他就像他们家庭的一员。
He's bald. There's a picture of him. That was our staff when everything happened.
他秃头。有一张他的照片。那是我们出事时的员工合影。
And that's him kneeling?
那是跪着的人吗？
That's him kneeling.
那是跪着的人。
Terry told us two interesting things about the year leading up to the murder. First, Vince had a bad car accident. He flipped his truck just off an exit ramp.
特里告诉了我们关于谋杀发生前那一年的两件趣事。首先，文斯出了一场严重的车祸。他在出口匝道附近把皮卡车翻了。
He hit a light pole and it-- the light pole came down and kind of went across his truck. They took him to the hospital. And I guess he had ID on him, is how they knew who he was. And they called Karen. But he told me at the hospital that he was Bobby Brown.
他撞上一根电线杆，电线杆倒下来横在车上。他们把他送到医院。我想他是带着身份证的，所以他们才知道他是谁。他们给凯伦打了电话。但他在医院告诉我他叫鲍比·布朗（Bobby Brown）。
He didn't know who he was. He didn't know who Karen was when she got there. He didn't know he was married. And then, that lasted for about 24 hours. And then they let him come home and he was kind of back to himself. But I think he had a pretty good bang to the head.
他不知道自己是谁。凯伦到的时候，他甚至认不出凯伦。他不知道自己结婚了。这种情况持续了大约24小时。然后他们让他回家，他恢复了正常。但我认为他头部撞得不轻。
Here's the strangest part. Terry said she thought Vince had maybe crashed his truck on purpose. He was scheduled to take his medical board exams at that time. And he was exceedingly anxious about them. He'd always been a bad test-taker. His mother told us he had attention deficit disorder as a kid. And Terry says it occurred to her that the accident was a way to avoid taking the boards.
最奇怪的部分来了。特里说她认为文斯可能是故意撞车的。当时他正计划参加医疗委员会考试。他对此极其焦虑。他一直是个糟糕的应试者。他母亲告诉我们他小时候患有多动症。特里说她想到，那次事故可能是一种逃避考试的方式。
And I think it was his way of getting out of it. Which, at the same time, he had wanted a new truck, too. And Karen-- Karen had told him he couldn't have a new truck. I mean, she was the one that kind of kept the, you know, the handle on the money. And he had his eye on this Toyota Tundra truck and a Toyota Tacoma. Anyway, he ended up with a new truck after the fact. So it could have been one of the two. I'm just saying.
我认为这是他摆脱考试的方法。而且同时，他也想要一辆新皮卡。凯伦——凯伦告诉过他不能买。我的意思是，她是那种控制财务的人。他看中了丰田坦途（Toyota Tundra）和塔科马（Tacoma）。总之，事后他确实开上了新皮卡。所以可能是这两个原因之一。我只是说说而已。
But that's crazy, though. That's, like, the riskiest behavior ever.
但这太疯狂了，那是最高风险的行为。
It is crazy.
确实疯狂。
Another friend who didn't want to go on tape also told us, unsolicited, that he thought Vince might've crashed his truck on purpose, possibly as a suicide attempt. Then, not too long after the truck accident, Vince and Karen split up, which floored their friends. Terry says it came out of nowhere.
另一位不愿录音的朋友也主动告诉我们，他认为文斯可能是故意撞车的，可能是一次自杀尝试。然后，在车祸发生后不久，文斯和凯伦离婚了，这让他们的朋友感到震惊。特里说这突如其来。
Just out of the blue, he came in one day and said him and Karen were getting a divorce. Nobody had a clue that they were even having any problems. She says, I asked him to go to counseling and everything. And he's like, no, I've already got a place to live. He went and found a place to live and moved out that weekend.
简直莫名其妙，有一天他来上班，说他和凯伦要离婚。没人知道他们之间甚至出了什么问题。她说，我让他去做心理咨询，什么都行。他说，不，我已经找好住处了。那个周末他就搬走了。
So you're saying everything seemed normal until that pronouncement? Like, he comes in and says, like, Karen and I are splitting? And then things changed from that moment, it feels like?
所以你是说在那句宣告之前一切看起来都很正常？比如，他进来就说，我和凯伦分开了？然后从那一刻起事情就变了？
Yeah. It was just like a-- it was like a light switch. But he just-- it's-- I thought it was a mid-life crisis. You know, sometimes men go through a midlife crisis and they go out and buy a car, go out and have an affair or something. We figured it would just blow over. And then, that's when he went out and started drinking, and we saw a side of him we had not seen before.
是的。就像一个——就像电灯开关一样。我以为是中年危机。你知道，有时男人会经历中年危机，他们会出去买车、出轨之类的。我们以为过段时间就好了。然后，那就是他开始酗酒的时候，我们看到了他从未显露的一面。
Vince's friends said he was drinking three or four nights a week, mostly at a bar in downtown Ashville called Jack of the Wood. But Terry says he's still seemed fine at work, and that he was fine the Monday they closed the clinic early, June 28, 2004, so that Vince could go pick up his father, Dalton Gilmer.
文斯的朋友们说他每周喝三四个晚上的酒，大多是在阿什维尔市中心一家叫“杰克之木”（Jack of the Wood）的酒吧。但特里说他在工作中看起来仍然没问题，2004年6月28日他们提前关闭诊所让他去接父亲道尔顿·吉尔默（Dalton Gilmer）时，他也很正常。
Dalton was at a psychiatric hospital. It's called Broughton Hospital. It's not clear what exactly was wrong with Dalton. But according to court records, he was taking antipsychotic medication and he needed help taking care of himself-- dressing, bathing, even eating sometimes. And he could barely walk. He needed a wheelchair or a walker. He was 60 years old.
道尔顿当时在一家精神病院。叫布劳顿医院（Broughton Hospital）。目前不清楚道尔顿到底有什么毛病。但根据法庭记录，他当时在服用抗精神病药物，需要人照顾——穿衣、洗澡，甚至吃饭。他几乎走不了路。他需要轮椅或助行器。他当时60岁。
Vince had made arrangements to transfer his father from Broughton to a nursing home very close to the Cane Creek Clinic. So that Monday afternoon, he drove up to Broughton and collected his father. I had every intention of taking him to the nursing home, Vince said at trial. But Vince says he promised to first take his dad to a favorite lake, several hours out of the way.
文斯安排把他父亲从布劳顿转到离甘蔗溪诊所很近的一家养老院。所以那个周一下午，他开车去布劳顿接父亲。我本打算带他去养老院的，文斯在庭审中说。但文斯说他答应先带他父亲去一个最喜欢的湖边，那是偏离路线好几个小时的地方。
He did have a big green kayak in the back of his truck, but remember, his dad can't walk. And Vince has no walker in the truck. Plus, it's getting late. So this plan didn't make much sense. The heart of Vince's story about the crime is probably something that, if you're listening with little kids right now, you might not want them to hear.
他车后确实有一艘绿色大皮划艇，但记住，他父亲不能走路。而且文斯车里没有助行器。况且，天色已晚。所以这个计划根本说不通。文斯关于犯罪的解释核心部分，如果您现在正带着小孩子听，可能不想让他们听到。
Vince says his father sexually abused him and his younger sister from the time they were 6 and three years old, respectively. The abuse he describes is maybe the most horrific I've ever heard of. Vince's sister apparently corroborated the abuse, but she disappeared just before the trial in 2005. And her family has not seen or heard from her since.
文斯说他父亲分别从他和妹妹6岁和3岁开始就对他们进行性虐待。他描述的虐待或许是我听过最恐怖的。文斯的妹妹显然证实了虐待，但在2005年审判前消失了。从那以后她的家人就再没见过她或听到过她的消息。
Vince's mother claims she never knew about the sexual abuse, not until after the murder. She said her husband was a Vietnam vet, who came back from the war a changed and sporadically violent man. Vince says his father was apt to make inappropriate sexual remarks and gropes, and that's what happened in the truck that day.
文斯的母亲声称直到谋杀案发生后才知道性虐待的事。她说她丈夫是越战老兵，战后变成了一个性情大变、偶尔暴力的人。文斯说他父亲喜欢做出不恰当的性暗示和摸索，那天在车里就是这样。
He kept saying filthy, filthy things, Vince said at trial. And that's when he lost it, he says. Vince said a voice in his head, like a compulsion, was telling him to kill his father. I reach over with the rope and I place the rope around his neck and pull on it and pull on it and pull on it. Then Vince says he drove around for hours, panicked, trying to figure out what to do with the body, which he'd moved to the bed of the pickup.
他一直在说肮脏、极其肮脏的话，文斯在庭审中说。就在那时他崩溃了。文斯说脑子里有个声音，像是一种强迫症，告诉他杀了父亲。我伸手拿绳子，把绳子套在他脖子上，勒紧、勒紧，一直勒紧。然后文斯说他开车转了好几个小时，惊慌失措，试图想办法处理尸体，他把尸体挪到了皮卡车斗里。
Eventually, he carried it onto the side of Good Hope Road, near the Virginia/Tennessee border. And he performed what the Virginia medical examiner would later describe as traumatic amputations of all 10 fingers. He cut off his father's fingers and thumbs. Vince says he used a little saw he had in the back of his truck for trees around the house. Vince said he did this to prevent the body from being identified.
最终，他把尸体抬到了好希望路（Good Hope Road）边，靠近弗吉尼亚州和田纳西州边界。他执行了后来弗吉尼亚州法医描述的“创伤性截肢”，切掉了父亲所有的10根手指和拇指。他切掉了他父亲的手指和拇指。文斯说他用了车里一把平时用来修剪家里树木的小锯子。文斯说他这样做是为了防止尸体被辨认出来。
And then, Vince went home. The body was quickly found, still warm, and quickly identified. In the pocket of his tanned shorts, in the inside color of his polo shirt, stamped in black ink, D. Gilmer. Name tags that Vince says he himself had arranged for.
然后，文斯回家了。尸体很快被发现，还有余温，并迅速被确认身份。在他的棕褐色短裤口袋里，在他马球衫内领上，用黑墨水印着“D. 吉尔默”。这些标签是文斯自己安排贴上去的。
After learning this much, Benjamin started conjuring a hypothesis about Vince. Benjamin did his master's thesis on traumatic brain injuries prior to Med school. To him, the truck accident was key to the whole thing. Maybe Vince had some lurking hereditary craziness that was unmasked by big bonk to the head. Or, in Benjamin's words, latent neurologic sequelae, triggered by brain trauma.
了解这些后，本杰明开始推测文斯的情况。本杰明在医学院之前主修过脑外伤的研究生论文。对他来说，车祸是整个事件的关键。也许文斯潜藏着某种遗传性的疯狂，被大脑的重击所触发。或者，用本杰明的词说，脑外伤引发的迟发性神经后遗症。
He was unconscious and didn't recognize his own wife afterwards. And then, after that period, there was a demarcation between this strange behavior that started happening. I think he had to be going crazy. I think the craziness started a year before the murder. Leaving a wife who loved him after so many years and assuming that she would stay in the practice and work side by side with him? That's not rational thinking.
他曾失去意识，事后甚至认不出自己的妻子。在那之后，奇怪的行为开始出现。我认为他一定疯了。我认为疯狂在谋杀前一年就开始了。在多年后抛弃深爱他的妻子，并假设她还会留在诊所和他并肩工作？那不是理性的想法。
If Vince snapped as he claimed, then it's hard to square his behavior immediately following the crime. Because from the sound of it, he told a cascade of lies coolly, no bead of sweat running down his temple.
如果文斯真的如他所说那般“瞬间崩溃”，那么他在犯罪后的行为就很难解释。因为听起来，他非常冷静地撒了一连串谎，额头上连一滴汗珠都没有。
On Tuesday, the day after the murder, Vince told his office manager, Terry Worley, and everyone else that he brought his father home. And that sometime during the night, his father had wandered off. He said he had people out looking. He filled out a police report, didn't cancel any appointments. In fact, the very first patient he saw was Terry's son, for asthma.
周二，谋杀发生后的第二天，文斯告诉办公室经理特里·沃利和其他人，他带父亲回家了。夜里某个时候，他父亲走失了。他说他派了人去寻找。他填了报警单，没有取消任何预约。事实上，他见的第一个病人就是特里的儿子，因为哮喘病。
He was totally normal. He was totally normal the whole time.
他完全正常。他整个过程完全正常。
Really?
真的吗？
He never broke down, seemed overly anxious because his dad was missing, nothing.
他没崩溃，没表现出因为父亲失踪而显得过分焦虑，什么都没有。
Vince kept seeing patients all week. Then on Friday, Vince invited the staff out to lunch at a favorite restaurant called Iannucci's. While they were there, he got a phone call from a detective, telling him they'd found a body in Virginia. Again, Terry Worley.
文斯整个星期都在看病人。然后周五，文斯邀请员工到一家名为Iannucci's的最爱餐厅吃午餐。他们在那儿时，他接到一位警探的电话，告诉他他们在弗吉尼亚州发现了一具尸体。同样是特里·沃利讲述。
And he just-- all color, he lost complete color and just-- he was in shock. I mean, he literally about passed out. He had to lay down on the bench at Iannucci's. And the woman got him a cold compress for his head.
他整个人——所有血色，他完全失去了血色，就像——他休克了。我的意思是，他差点当场昏过去。他在Iannucci's的长椅上躺了下来。那个女人给了他一块冷敷布敷头。
I don't know what was going through his head, if he was thinking, oh, crap, I'm caught. Or, now I've got to cover my tracks. I don't know what he thought. And he just-- as he was handing me the phone, he says, you have to talk to my office manager. And kind of shoved the phone to me.
我不知道他脑子里在想什么，他是在想“糟了，我被抓了”，还是“现在我得掩盖痕迹”。我不知道他在想什么。他递给我电话时说，你得和我的办公室经理谈谈。然后把电话推给了我。
Benjamin and I talked to this detective. His name is Mike Martin. Benjamin was on speaker phone.
本杰明和我与这位警探谈过。他叫迈克·马丁（Mike Martin）。本杰明开了免提。
Does this case stand out to you in your professional life?
这起案件在您的职业生涯中突出吗？
It is a unique case, as in he was able to kill his father and show no remorse.
这是一个独特的案例，因为他能杀死父亲却表现得毫无悔意。
Detective Martin says when he showed up at Vince's door, Vince was cordial and composed.
马丁警探说，当他出现在文斯门口时，文斯表现得很礼貌、沉着。
During the interview at Mr. Gilmer's home, he told me that he had brought his father to North Carolina to stay with him. And that upon their arrival, that Daddy was so delighted to be there that he had went out into the yard and played with the dog, throwing a Frisbee.
在吉尔默先生家的采访中，他告诉我他把父亲带到北卡罗来纳州和他住在一起。到达后，爸爸很高兴来到这里，走到院子里和狗一起玩飞盘。
I already knew that could not be true, because the people at Broughton Hospital told me that Mr. Gilmer senior could not have walked on his own at any time. He said, you don't believe what I'm telling you. I said, no, sir. Not at all. Not in the least. I do not believe you.
我早就知道那不可能是真的，因为布劳顿医院的人告诉我，老吉尔默先生在任何时候都不可能独自走路。他说，你不相信我说的。我说，不，先生。一点也不。我不相信。
I said, the very questions that any person would be asking in reference to his parent death, you have not asked, which is an excellent indicator that you already know. He wasn't scared. He wasn't agitated.
我说，关于父亲死亡，任何正常人都会问的问题，你一个都没问，这极好地证明了你早就知道。他不害怕，也不激动。
He told me, he said, look. He said, you do not know who you are messing with. He said, I am a doctor of medicine. I am well respected in the state of North Carolina. And I will have your damned job.
他告诉我，他说，听着。他说，你不知道你在跟谁作对。他说，我是医学博士。我在北卡罗来纳州备受尊敬。我会让你丢掉这份该死的工作。
I said, sir, it is my job to do the investigation. And based on what I know, I will consult with the Commonwealth attorney. And I will ask for a warrant for your arrest for murder. When we left, we said, sir, thank you for your time. And he closed the door and never said a word.
我说，先生，调查是我的工作。根据我知道的情况，我会咨询联邦检察官。我会申请逮捕令，以谋杀罪名逮捕你。我们离开时，我们说，先生，谢谢你的时间。他关上门，一个字也没说。
Before Detective Martin could get back to Cane Creek with a warrant, Vince ran, took some camping equipment and hid out. The cops finally caught up with him in the woods near the Lowe's hardware store at the Asheville mall.
在马丁警探带着逮捕令返回甘蔗溪之前，文斯逃跑了，带着一些露营装备躲了起来。警察最终在阿什维尔购物中心的一家劳氏（Lowe's）五金店附近的树林里抓住了他。
Did you come away thinking this was a premeditated-- like he planned this murder in advance and then executed it?
你是认为这是蓄意谋杀吗？他提前计划好了谋杀，然后实施了？
That is exactly what I think.
我就是这么想的。
Really?
真的吗？
Yes, ma'am.
是的。
That it wasn't a spur of the moment, he kind of lost control and years of abuse and anger welled up and overpowered him?
不是那种一时冲动，多年虐待和愤怒涌上心头压倒了他？
Spur of the moment didn't buy the gloves. It didn't buy the rope. And it didn't put the pruning shears in the pickup truck.
一时冲动买不到手套。买不到绳子。也不会把修枝剪放进皮卡里。
Other things Benjamin and I learned from Terry Worley. Vince was his father's guardian. He was supposed to be paying his father's bills out of his father's money, but he didn't. By the time he killed his father, he owed the psychiatric hospital where his father had been staying more than $270,000. A motive, maybe. Also, Vince had planned a two week vacation to Alaska that coincided with his father's killing. Terry says the investigators questioned her about it.
本杰明和我从特里·沃利那里还了解到其他情况。文斯是他父亲的监护人。他本应花父亲的钱支付父亲的账单，但他没这么做。在他杀父亲时，他已经欠父亲住的那家精神病院超过27万美元了。这可能是一个动机。此外，文斯还计划了去阿拉斯加的两周假期，正好与他杀害父亲的时间重合。特里说调查人员询问了她这件事。
They asked me if I knew it was a one way ticket. I said, no, I helped him book it. And they showed me where it had been changed to a one-way flight. So he wasn't planning on coming back. He thought he was going to get gone.
他们问我是否知道那是张单程票。我说，不，我帮他订的。他们给我看了那张票是如何被改为单程航班的。所以他根本没打算回来。他以为他会远走高飞。
By the time we'd finished talking to Terry, Benjamin was deflated. Vince was sounding more and more like this cold-blooded killer. We debriefed.
当我们谈完话，本杰明灰心丧气。文斯听起来越来越像个冷血杀手。我们进行了总结。
It just seems like he's lying. It just seems to me like he's lying.
他看起来就像在撒谎。我觉得他就是在撒谎。
You really believe that?
你真的相信吗？
I think he's lying about this having snapped. I do. I think I do. I mean it just doesn't-- it doesn't make sense with all the things that Terry said. This is a guy who had made a plan, no?
我觉得他在“瞬间崩溃”这件事上撒谎。我确实这么认为。我的意思是，这和特里说的所有事情都对不上。这是一个做过计划的家伙，不是吗？
It seems that way now, doesn't it?
现在看起来确实是这样，不是吗？
To me, it does.
对我来说，是这样。
Yeah. That's a total game changer. That's-- that's not crazy. That is rational planning with a motive. I was kind of hoping not to hear that.
是的。这完全颠覆了局面。这不是疯狂。这是带有动机的理性计划。我本来希望听到的不是这个。
Soon after Vince Gilmer was caught by the police, he confessed to strangling his father. His defense boiled down to one word, serotonin. That was his excuse, his disease, his all-purpose defect, serotonin. Or rather, lack of serotonin in his brain.
文斯·吉尔默被警察抓住后不久，他承认勒死了父亲。他的辩护归结为一个词：血清素。那是他的借口，他的疾病，他的万能缺陷，血清素。或者更确切地说，大脑缺乏血清素。
Serotonin is a hormone, a neurotransmitter. If you don't have the right level of it in your brain, it can affect your mood, which is why many antidepressants increase your serotonin level. These drugs are called SSRIs, Selective Serotonin Reuptake Inhibitors. If you stop taking them abruptly, you can have suicidal thoughts, severe agitation, even psychosis.
血清素是一种激素、一种神经递质。如果你大脑里的水平不正常，就会影响情绪，这就是为什么许多抗抑郁药会提高血清素水平。这些药物被称为SSRIs，即选择性5-羟色胺再摄取抑制剂。如果你突然停药，可能会有自杀念头、严重躁动，甚至精神病。
What you believe about Vince's crime depends on whether you believe he was out of his mind at the time of the killing, whether you believe that missing his SSRI pills could transform him from a loving doctor into a psycho. Here's Vince's explanation for what happened.
你相信文斯的犯罪行为，取决于你是否相信他在杀人时已经失去了理智，是否相信错过SSRIs药物就能把他从一个慈爱的医生变成一个疯子。这是文斯对所发生之事的解释。
He'd been struggling with anxiety for years. And after he and Karen split up, in the months leading up to the murder, he'd been taking Lexapro, an SSRI. He says a day or two before he went to pick up his dad, he stopped the Lexapro. Didn't taper it off like you're supposed to, he just stopped. And he reacted very badly.
他多年来一直为焦虑所苦。和凯伦离婚后，在谋杀案发生前的几个月里，他一直在服用来士普（Lexapro），一种SSRI。他说在他去接父亲的一两天前，他停了药。没有按照要求慢慢减量，他直接停了。结果他反应非常糟糕。
He became extraordinarily irritable, heard voices. His brain didn't work right, he said. He felt, quote, "mentally retarded". In a letter to a doctor he wrote from jail, this is how he describes the voices he heard when he was off the Lexapro.
他变得异常易怒，听到声音。他的大脑运转不正常，他说。他觉得，引用他的话，“智力受损”。在狱中写给一位医生的一封信里，他是这样描述停药后听到的声音的。
"These are not voices that make a suggestion. This is a compulsion. The compulsion is trying to take over my consciousness. I fight the compulsion in the front part of my head. It is a hyperanxious state. Pacing becomes mandatory, trying to walk off the pressure. The battle hurts badly."
“这些声音不是提供建议。这是一种强迫感。强迫感试图接管我的意识。我在大脑前部抵御这种强迫感。这是一种极度焦虑的状态。必须不停踱步，试图走掉压力。这种斗争痛不欲生。”
One of the phrases he kept using over and over was that, my brain wasn't working right. You know, my head wasn't working right.
他反复使用的词句之一就是，我的大脑运转不正常。你知道，我的头运转不正常。
This is reporter Matt Lakin. Back in 2004, he was covering crime for the Bristol Herald Courier. He spoke to Vince soon after the murder, both on the phone and in person. And Matt says Vince seemed like an intelligent guy, a nice guy, pleasant to talk to. Not obviously crazy, maybe just eccentric and a little manipulative.
这是记者马特·莱金（Matt Lakin）。回到2004年，他在报道布里斯托尔先驱信使报（Bristol Herald Courier）的犯罪新闻。他在谋杀案发生后不久就与文斯谈过，无论是电话里还是本人。马特说文斯看起来是个聪明人，好人，交谈愉快。不明显是疯子，也许只是古怪且有一点操纵欲。
He would go into these bizarre-- he'd make these strange gestures, where he would bob his head up and down and just sort of kind of shake. He would-- it was just almost, you know, I almost had a sense that he was hamming it up sometimes.
他会陷入那种奇怪的——他会做奇怪的手势，把头上下摆动，然后有点发抖。他会——我甚至有一种感觉，他有时是在演戏。
Like doing it for your benefit.
就像为了你的利益而演。
Right. I mean, whenever I would point out a flaw in his story, for example, he would suddenly get emotional and start to cry. So either he was having tremendous mood swings, or he was trying to avoid the question. Which one do you think it was?
没错。我的意思是，每当我指出他故事里的漏洞时，比如，他会突然变得情绪化并开始哭泣。所以要么他是情绪波动巨大，要么他是在试图回避问题。你觉得是哪一个？
This question lurked throughout Vince's initial incarceration and court appearances. Was he crazy? Or was he crazy like a fox? We asked Mike Martin, the Virginia detective in charge of the murder investigation, whether he ever saw evidence of mental illness in Vince, whether he ever questioned if the cops had gotten it wrong.
这个问题一直困扰着文斯最初的监禁和出庭。他疯了吗？还是狐狸般狡猾？我们问了负责谋杀调查的弗吉尼亚州警探迈克·马丁，他是否见过文斯患精神病的证据，是否质疑过警察是否弄错了。
I can tell you what we done for Mr. Gilmer. We got to watching him. And each time, police officers would come around him, he would--
我可以告诉你我们对吉尔默先生做了什么。我们开始监视他。每一次，当警察出现在他周围时，他就会——
Detective Martin said he and his fellow officers had noticed Vince shaking his arm and his head, and that he only seemed to do it around them, not around the other inmates. They were suspicious.
马丁警探说他和同事注意到文斯在摇晃手臂和头部，而且他似乎只在警察面前才这么做，在其他犯人面前不会。他们很怀疑。
So we set up a camera on the rec yard, and invited the inmates out on the rec yard to play. And they played basketball. Mr. Gilmer participated in playing basketball as the rest did. He participated in the walks around the yards as the rest did. And then we purposely sent the officer, James Blevins, who was assisting me in this case. When Mr. Gilmer seen the officer, he automatically started to shake the head and arm. And he did that until such time that Detective Blevins left the rec yard. Mr. Gilmer is not somebody that's been controlled by some demon. He is very self-controlled.
所以我们在娱乐场设置了一个摄像头，邀请犯人出去打球。他们打篮球。吉尔默先生像其他人一样参与打篮球。他像其他人一样在操场走动。然后我们故意派协助此案的警官詹姆斯·布莱文斯（James Blevins）过去。当吉尔默看到警官时，他自动开始摇晃头和手臂。他一直持续到布莱文斯警探离开操场。吉尔默不是那种被恶魔控制的人。他非常有自控力。
A clinical psychologist named Jeffrey Feix came to a similar conclusion. Feix evaluated Vince to find out if he was sane at the time of the crime. He reported that Vince was agitated, quote, "spoke in a halting fashion, fidgeted while sitting, stood with a stooped posture, occasionally paced, and gesticulated broadly with his hands while talking. This presentation was very dramatic and not consistent with known anxiety or psychotic disorders."
一位名叫杰弗里·费克斯（Jeffrey Feix）的临床心理学家得出了类似的结论。费克斯评估了文斯，以确定他在犯罪时是否清醒。他报告说文斯情绪激动，引用道：“说话方式支支吾吾，坐着时局促不安，站着时身体佝偻，偶尔踱步，说话时双手大幅度比划。这种表现非常做作，与已知的焦虑或精神疾病不符。”
Feix went on, "it appeared that the patient was exaggerating his symptoms for the benefit of the evaluator and treatment team. It is respectfully recommended that Dr. Gilmer be considered legally sane at the time of the offense." Later that fall, another psychiatrist found Vince to be quote, "evasive, dramatic, and manipulative." And by mid-2006, the prison doctors had settled on a two-pronged diagnosis-- atypical depression and malingering. In other words, lying.
费克斯继续说：“看起来该患者是为了评估人员和治疗团队的利益而夸大其词。特此建议吉尔默医生在案发时应被视为具有完全法律行为能力。”同年秋天晚些时候，另一位精神科医生发现文斯引用道：“逃避、戏剧化且有操纵性。”到2006年中期，监狱医生已经确定了双重诊断——非典型抑郁症和装病。换句话说，撒谎。
From jury selection forward, the trial was a disaster for Vince. His performance, his explanations, they appeared to move no one. I talked to a man named Robert Hughes, who was called to serve on the jury, though eventually excused. When he would talk to us, Mr. Hughes said of Vince, he would act like he was nuts. Then, when he turned around to talk to his lawyers, he was as cool as anything.
从挑选陪审团开始，审判对文斯来说就是一场灾难。他的表现、他的解释，似乎没打动任何人。我采访了一个叫罗伯特·休斯（Robert Hughes）的男人，他曾被传唤担任陪审员，尽管后来被免职。在与我们交谈时，休斯先生谈到文斯，他会表现得像个疯子。然后，当他转过身和律师交谈时，他又冷静得不得了。
We argued at trial that he was planning his defense, essentially, prior to committing the crime in the first place.
我们在审判中辩称他在犯罪之前基本上就已经在策划辩护方案了。
Nicole Price was one of the prosecutors. When she lists all the evidence, the state's case sounds pretty straightforward. Vince had made careful plans to pick his father up. He had all the materials he needed to carry out the crime right there in his truck. He mutilated the body to hide the identity, and then dumped it in Virginia, far from where he himself lived.
尼科尔·普莱斯（Nicole Price）是检察官之一。当她列出所有证据时，国家的案件听起来相当明确。文斯为去接父亲做了周密的计划。他在皮卡车里就拥有实施犯罪所需的所有材料。他损毁尸体以隐藏身份，然后弃尸于弗吉尼亚，离他自己居住的地方很远。
And the other evidence that we had were conversations, recorded conversations that he had with friends. And in those conversations, he talks about using the-- you know, playing the good doctor card as hard as we can. He talks about that he would prefer to be tried in Tennessee, because he felt that his sentence would be less.
我们拥有的另一个证据是对话，他和朋友们的录音对话。在那些对话里，他谈到要尽可能地打出“好医生”这张牌。他谈到他更希望在田纳西州受审，因为他觉得在那里的判决会轻一些。
And so, at different times, he advised law enforcement that the murder occurred in North Carolina, that it occurred in Virginia, and that it occurred in Tennessee. And that was calculated to let him determine where this trial would be had. So I think the evidence from his own mouth is that he was manipulating, in the hopes that he would convince a jury that he was not responsible for his criminal actions, because of some type of-- I don't know. That he was insane.
所以在不同时期，他向执法部门声称谋杀发生在北卡罗来纳州、弗吉尼亚州和田纳西州。这是经过计算的，为了让他决定在哪里受审。所以我认为他亲口说的证据证明他在操纵，希望说服陪审团相信他不对自己的犯罪行为负责，因为某种……我不知道。因为他疯了。
And what is the craziest thing a man accused of first degree murder can do? The craziest, most stark-raving lunatic thing a man facing life in prison can do? The answer is dismiss his lawyers and choose to represent himself. And so, yes, that is what Vince Gilmer did.
被控一级谋杀罪的男人能做的最疯狂的事情是什么？一个面临终身监禁的男人能做的最疯狂、最歇斯底里的疯子行为是什么？答案是解雇律师，选择自我辩护。是的，这就是文斯·吉尔默所做的。
I used to be a court reporter. And so, I read a lot of court transcripts, but none as farcical as this one. It makes you wonder if maybe he really was crazy, because any casual watcher of Law & Order could have built a better case for himself than Vince Gilmer. His witnesses are beside the point. His own testimony favors the nonsensical. Vince can barely string together a sentence before a prosecutor objects.
我曾经是一名法庭速记员。所以，我读过很多法庭记录，但没有比这一份更荒唐的了。这让人怀疑他是不是真的疯了，因为任何《法律与秩序》（Law & Order）的随便观众都能比文斯·吉尔默做出更好的辩护。他的证人无关紧要。他自己的证词偏向无意义。文斯还没能把一个句子说完整，检察官就提出反对了。
At one point, Vince called his ex-girlfriend, Susan Garren to the stand. He asks her, "to the best of your knowledge, have I hurt anyone or killed anyone? Just have I hurt or killed anyone that you know of?" Susan, "Your father." Vince, "OK that-- have I besides what happened with my dad?" Susan, "Can you repeat the question, please?"
有一次，文斯传唤了他的前女友苏珊·加伦（Susan Garren）上庭。他问她：“据你所知，我伤害过谁或杀过谁吗？仅仅是你知道的我伤害或杀过谁吗？”苏珊：“你父亲。”文斯：“好的——除了发生在我爸身上的事外，还有吗？”苏珊：“你能重复一下问题吗，请？”
His court-appointed attorney, who was there only to answer Vince's questions about court procedure, said it was agonizing to watch, like someone trying to commit suicide with a butter knife. Toward the end of the trial, Vince Gilmer says, Your Honor, I'd like to call Vince Gilmer. He talks and he talks and he talks for nearly two hours. And by the end, he loses his thread.
他的法庭指定律师，只负责回答文斯关于法庭程序的问题，说这看起来很痛苦，就像有人试图用一把黄油刀自杀。在审判即将结束时，文斯·吉尔默说：“法官阁下，我想传唤文斯·吉尔默。”他说了又说，说了近两个小时。到最后，他失去了逻辑。
The prison docs have stopped his SSRIs meds, he said. "So when I came in here, I'm confused. I had trouble-- I've had trouble with the confusion all the way through this. I know you're the jury, and I know he's the judge, so that makes me in Virginia-- you're-- I'm capable to-- I'm able to say I'm competent to be here. This hasn't been the brightest of ideas, being my own lawyer."
监狱医生停了他的SSRI药物，他说。“所以我进来时很困惑。我很难——我一直被这种困惑困扰着。我知道你们是陪审团，我知道他是法官，这让我有能力说，我是清醒的，我能胜任在这里。这并不是什么好主意，做自己的律师。”
A little later, prosecutor Nicole Price interjects. "Isn't it true that you've been found competent to represent yourself?" "I am," says Vince. "Are you fine right now?" Ms. Price asks. "No," says Vince.
过了一会儿，检察官尼科尔·普莱斯插话道：“你被认定有能力代表自己，这不是真的吗？”“我是，”文斯说。“你现在状态还好吗？”普莱斯女士问。“不，”文斯说。
The jury took about an hour to convict Vince Gilmer of first degree murder. The judge, the Honorable C. Randall Lowe concurred. Quote, "it was clear that it was malingering and faking," he said at a post-trial hearing. "The defendant would go into an act. He would look up and see if the jury was buying it. When the jury wasn't buying it, he would go back to normal. It was clear."
陪审团花了一个小时裁定文斯·吉尔默一级谋杀罪成立。法官C·兰德尔·洛（C. Randall Lowe）表示赞同。引用道：“很明显，这是装病和伪装，”他在审判后听证会上说。“被告在演戏。他会抬头看陪审团是否买账。当陪审团不买账时，他就会恢复正常。很明显。”
Judge Lowe sentenced Vince to life in prison without the possibility of parole. So that's where it ended. The entire law enforcement, medical, and legal community declared Vince a liar. He went to a maximum security prison called Wallens Ridge in the mountains of far Western Virginia.
洛法官判处文斯终身监禁，不得假释。事情就是这样结束的。整个执法、医疗和法律界都宣布文斯是个骗子。他被送往弗吉尼亚州最远端的山区，一个叫沃伦斯岭（Wallens Ridge）的高度设防监狱。
Coming up, Benjamin does not take premeditated for an answer. A hunch, a blood test, and DNA evidence. And not the kind you're thinking of. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
稍后，本杰明不会接受“蓄意谋杀”这个结论。一个预感、一份验血报告和DNA证据。不是你想象中的那种。稍后从芝加哥公共广播电台继续播放。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, Dr. Gilmer and Mr. Hyde. If you just tuned in, Dr. Benjamin Gilmer is looking into a murder committed by Dr. Vince Gilmer, no relation. Where we left off before the break, Vince Gilmer was claiming that his brain was not functioning properly at the time of the murder.
这是《This American Life》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目主题是“吉尔默医生与海德先生”。如果你刚调入，本杰明·吉尔默医生正在调查由文斯·吉尔默医生犯下的一起谋杀案，两人毫无关系。中断前我们讲到，文斯·吉尔默声称他在谋杀时大脑运转不正常。
Two psychiatrists and a psychologist thought he was faking his supposed symptoms of a mental disturbance. A jury thought he was faking, a judge thought he was faking. Our reporter on the case, Sarah Koenig, was inclined to think that all these people cannot probably be wrong. And the one person-- the one person-- who still thinks that maybe Vince Gilmer might not be faking is Benjamin Gilmer.
两位精神科医生和一位心理学家认为他是在伪装所谓的精神紊乱症状。陪审团认为他在伪装，法官也认为他在伪装。我们此案的记者莎拉·柯尼格倾向于认为所有这些人不可能都错。而唯一一个——唯一一个——仍然认为文斯·吉尔默可能没在伪装的人，是本杰明·吉尔默。
He's still unconvinced. He's begun researching SSRI withdrawal, and found dozens and dozens of reports of people who've become violent or homicidal while either on or off their medication. He's also gathered more reports of personality changes following a traumatic brain injury. And he's dug up Vince's brain scan from back when he had the truck accident, and got over it with not one, but two radiologists.
他仍然不相信。他开始研究SSRI戒断反应，并发现了数十份关于人们在服药或停药期间变得暴力或杀人的报告。他还收集了更多脑外伤后人格改变的报告。他翻出了文斯当年车祸时的脑部扫描图，并与不仅一位，而是两位放射科医生进行了讨论。
When Benjamin calls me to talk about what he's found, he sounds to me like he's grasping for a diagnosis. Benjamin wrote to Vince in prison. And several weeks later, he got a letter back. Vince included many pages of information about SSRI withdrawal, and had written messages on the back in a mad man's scrawl, barely comprehensible.
当本杰明打电话告诉我他的发现时，听起来他像是在拼命寻找一个诊断结果。本杰明给监狱里的文斯写了信。几周后，他收到了回信。文斯在信里附上了许多关于SSRI戒断反应的资料，背面上用疯子般的字迹写着几乎无法辨认的消息。
Six years into this, I mean, the guy, he's exhibiting the same kind of behavior.
这事已经过去六年了，我的意思是，这家伙还在表现出同样的行为。
Right. You'd figure if he was-- if he were faking, he'd let it go. Like, what's the point now?
没错。你以为如果他是在——如果他是在装，他早就放弃了。就像，现在还有什么意义？
Yeah. Just believing he's just a pathologic, sociopathic killer who did it in cold blood and that it was-- that he's just that, that I do not believe anymore. I really-- he was a mess.
是的。仅仅相信他是一个冷血杀人的病态社会性杀手，而且那只是——我不相信那是他了。真的——他当时陷入了混乱。
Yeah. I don't know. I don't think you're going to get to the bottom of this, Benjamin.
是的。我不知道。我觉得你找不到真相的，本杰明。
You don't think it's ever going to be--
你觉得永远不会有——
I don't think it's ever going to be clear. I mean, I think you can end up telling yourself something about it, but I don't know that it's going to be true.
我觉得真相永远不会大白。我的意思是，我觉得你最后能对自己讲述一个版本，但我不知道那是否是事实。
I mean, I'm not trying to make him a martyr or anything.
我是说，我不是想把他塑造成烈士之类的。
I know. I know. I'm just saying. But you want to know the truth about it, though.
我知道。我知道。我只是说说而已。但你想知道关于它的真相。
Yeah. Here we are.
是的。这就是现状。
It seemed the only way to judge Vince for ourselves was to see him for ourselves. So in January, Benjamin and I drove to Wallens Ridge state prison to meet Vince.
看来判断文斯的唯一方法就是亲自见他。所以一月份，本杰明和我开车前往沃伦斯岭州立监狱见文斯。
How are you feeling?
你感觉怎么样？
I'm feeling nervous, to be honest. Never done this before.
老实说，我很紧张。从来没做过这种事。
Benjamin was so nervous, he had to sit down when we were signing in at the front desk. He told me later he was imagining being face to face with a guy capable of tearing someone apart. That's the way one of the jail guards back in North Carolina had described Vince to Benjamin.
本杰明太紧张了，在前台登记时不得不坐下来。他后来告诉我，他想象着与一个有能力撕碎他人的人面对面。那是北卡罗来纳州的一位监狱看守对本杰明描述文斯的样子。
Now, at Wallens Ridge, they led us to the visiting room. Several other inmates were already there. And after a while, they brought in an old man. At least, he looked like an old man, bent and shuffling. And, of course, that was Vince. He's only 50, but he looks awful.
现在，在沃伦斯岭，他们把我们领进探视室。其他几名犯人已经在那里了。过了一会儿，他们带来了一个老人。至少看起来像个老人，弯着腰蹒跚走来。当然，那就是文斯。他才50岁，但看起来很糟糕。
We spent four hours talking to him, asking him every question we had and continually fetching him food from the vending machines. Two pizza burgers with pepperoni, one cheddar cheese burger, two Cokes, and six of those pink Hostess snowballs, coated with coconut shavings.
我们花了四个小时和他交谈，问了他所有的问题，并不停地从自动售货机买食物给他。两个意大利辣香肠披萨汉堡，一个切达干酪汉堡，两瓶可乐，还有六个那种涂满椰子碎的粉红色Hostess雪球甜点。
Ever since Vince went to jail in 2004, he has been agitating. And all this time, he has never let up. It's dizzying, the amount of paperwork he's filed, protesting what he says is inhumane treatment. Inmate request forms and civil lawsuits and motions for emergency hearings.
自从2004年文斯进监狱以来，他一直在申诉。这么久以来，他从未停止过。他提交的文件数量令人眼花缭乱，抗议他所说的不人道待遇。犯人请求表格、民事诉讼和紧急听证会申请。
Vince insists he has SSRI Withdrawal Syndrome, an extreme reaction to changes in his SSRI meds that can cause intolerable mood changes. If only they'd give him 60 or 80 or 100 milligrams of Celexa, uncrushed, he'd be better. A fellow inmate who tried to help Vince wrote to me. At Wallens Ridge, they call Vince Doc.
文斯坚持认为他患有SSRI戒断综合征，这是对SSRI药物改变的一种极端反应，会导致难以忍受的情绪变化。如果他们能给他60、80或100毫克未磨碎的西普兰（Celexa），他就会好起来。一位试图帮助文斯的狱友写信给我。在沃伦斯岭，他们叫文斯“医生”。
The inmate wrote, quote, "when the prison doctors would not order the treatment Doc wanted based on his self-diagnosis, he would become hostile, threatening, throw tantrums, refused to comply with orders, and just yelled that all of this was caused by his serotonin-deprived brain. Needless to say, none of that plays well in prison. Sadly, Doc has been his own worst enemy." Unquote.
这位狱友写道，引用：“当监狱医生不根据他的自我诊断开出‘医生’想要的药物时，他就会变得敌意、威胁、发脾气、拒绝遵守命令，并且只会大喊大叫，说这一切都是由他缺乏血清素的大脑引起的。不用说，在监狱里这些都没用。悲哀的是，‘医生’成了他自己最大的敌人。”引用结束。
We weren't allowed to record or take written notes when we met with Vince, but the following day, we were allowed to record a phone call. The sound quality is not good.
我们见文斯时不允许录音或记笔记，但第二天，我们被允许录下一通电话。音质不好。
Hello? Hello?
喂？喂？
Hi.
嘿。
Are you there?
你在那吗？
Yeah. Is that Vince?
在。是文斯吗？
Yes. I can hear you.
是的。我能听到你。
Oh, great.
哦，太好了。
Good morning.
早上好。
Vince is hard to take in, because he presents so many contradictory characteristics all at once. You can see he was once a handsome guy. And at times, his speech and thoughts and affect seem completely normal. He looks you straight in the eyes. And some of his answers sound utterly reasonable, too.
文斯很难读懂，因为他同时呈现出这么多矛盾的特征。你可以看出他曾经是个帅气的家伙。有时，他的言谈、思想和情感看起来完全正常。他直视你的眼睛。他的一些回答听起来也完全合理。
For instance, no, he did not simply dump his wife and walk away from a happy marriage. They were having troubles, like many couples do. And they couldn't work out those troubles, so they split up, he said. End of story. We later confirmed this with Karen.
例如，不，他并不是简单地抛弃妻子、放弃幸福婚姻。他们像许多夫妇一样遇到了麻烦。他说，他们无法解决那些问题，所以分开了。故事就此结束。我们后来向凯伦证实了这一点。
But then, in a flash, he'll lose his focus, lose simple words, become weepy. His face will grimace strangely, in a way that's unconnected to what he's saying. Or he's putting his index finger on his chin or forehead and looking at the ceiling like a child.
但随后，瞬间，他会失去注意力，想不起简单的词汇，变得爱哭。他的脸会做出奇怪的鬼脸，与他说的内容完全无关。或者他把食指放在下巴或额头上，像个孩子一样看着天花板。
His hands are working constantly, especially his left hand, rubbing his thumb endlessly over his closed fingers. You can see the skin is red and raw from it. He's holding his arms close to his chest. He's talking and talking. And then he'll stop and say, what was the question?
他的手不停地动，尤其是左手，用大拇指没完没了地揉搓紧闭的指头。你可以看到皮肤因此又红又烂。他紧紧抱着双臂。他一直在说，然后会停下来问，问题是什么？
Vince is missing many teeth. He says that's because his serotonin-deprived brain makes him aggressive, and so he lashes out at other inmates and then gets beaten down by prison guards. I ran this by a Virginia DOC official, who said the DOC does not respond publicly to inmate allegations. Benjamin spent a lot of the conversation trying to suss out Vince's medical history.
文斯的牙齿缺了很多。他说那是由于他缺乏血清素的大脑让他变得有攻击性，所以他攻击其他犯人，然后被监狱看守暴打。我把这件事告诉了弗吉尼亚州惩教署的一位官员，对方称该部门不对犯人的指控做出公开回应。本杰明花了大量时间试图厘清文斯的病史。
So what is the difference between a serotonin-deprived brain and depression? I'm just trying to figure out.
那么缺乏血清素的大脑和抑郁症有什么区别？我只是试图弄明白。
Um, [INAUDIBLE] OK. Instead of being-- OK. Unbelievable levels of anxiety, um, uh. Like I said, ungodly anxiety, electrical jellyfish stings. It comes and goes.
嗯，[听不清]好的。不是——好的。难以置信的焦虑水平，嗯，呃。就像我说过，不共戴天的焦虑，电水母刺痛。时有时无。
That was a little hard to hear. He's saying, electric jellyfish stings. He says that's what it feels like in his brain, an electric shock.
听不太清楚。他说，电水母刺痛。他说那感觉就像在他脑子里，像电击。
Um, what was your question?
嗯，你的问题是什么？
Then he says there's the intermittent psychomotor agitation, meaning the uncontrolled movements in his arms and face that come and go. He knows it looks fake, he says, but it's real. And indeed, the symptoms he talks about are listed in the teeny tiny print on the back of the Lexapro insert. I asked him about what Detective Martin told us, about putting cameras in the jail rec yard, and how Vince seemed to act weird only when staff came around.
然后他说还有阵发性的精神运动躁动，意思是他手臂和脸上无法控制的动作，时有时无。他说他知道看起来像装的，但这是真实的。事实上，他谈到的症状在来士普（Lexapro）包装说明书背面的超小号字体里都有列出。我问他关于马丁警探告诉我们的，关于在监狱娱乐场装摄像头的事，以及为什么文斯似乎只在工作人员出现时才表现奇怪。
That's exactly. That's intermittent psychomotor agitation, exactly. And same thing happens when I try to talk to medical people, same thing, same type of thing.
正是这样。那是阵发性的精神运动躁动，完全是。当我尝试和医务人员交谈时也一样，同一种情况。
I see.
我明白了。
Or if something, like, stresses me out. It gets worse and worse and worse and worse and worse and worse and worse and worse and worse.
或者如果什么事让他压力大。它会变得越来越糟，越来越糟，越来越糟。
So basically, what Detective Martin saw as evidence of you faking it, you're saying it's evidence of a real syndrome.
所以基本上，马丁警探认为这是你装病的证据，而你却说这是真正综合征的证据。
Absolutely. And that's a documented part.
绝对是。这是有据可查的部分。
No one has believed you. They don't believe your symptoms are real. Why is that?
没人相信你。他们不相信你的症状是真实的。为什么？
I don't know. I don't understand.
我不知道。我不明白。
Vince told us he did not plan to kill his father. He's adamant about that. He says he did not want his father dead. He'd taken care of his father on many occasions, sometimes for long stretches. The plane ticket to Alaska that Terry told us about? Vince couldn't remember it. And it never came up as evidence in court.
文斯告诉我们他没计划杀他父亲。他对此坚信不疑。他说他不想让他父亲死。他在许多场合照顾过他父亲，有时长达很长一段时间。特里告诉我们的去阿拉斯加的机票？文斯记不得了。而且那从来没有作为法庭证据出现。
As for the debt Vince owed to Broughton Hospital, he says he just wasn't that worried about it. Plus, it's not like the debt would have gone away if his father died. But he couldn't explain why he'd let it accrue like that, why he never paid for his father's care like he was supposed to. Also, he couldn't really explain his behavior right after the killing.
至于文斯欠布劳顿医院的债务，他说他只是没那么担心。此外，并不是说他父亲死了债务就消失了。但他无法解释为什么他会让债务堆积，为什么他从来没有像他应该做的那样支付他父亲的护理费用。此外，他无法真正解释他在杀人后的行为。
I just can't bring-- come up with a good answer for it. Sorry.
我就是找不到好的答案。抱歉。
Because I am curious about that week. Because it seems like you were very-- you were very controlled, in fact, in that week.
因为我对那个星期感到好奇。因为看起来你非常——事实上那个星期你非常冷静。
By that time, I was back on that medicine for a short term.
那时候，我又短期吃上了药。
So are you saying that as soon as you took the Lexapro again, your mind calmed down and you were able to kind of go about your life in a more or less normal way?
所以你是说一旦你重新服用来士普（Lexapro），你的头脑平静下来，你就能以一种或多或少正常的方式生活了？
Absolutely. Yes.
绝对是。是的。
So why, at that point, if you're on it, why not just immediately go to the police and say, like, I've done this horrible thing. And I was out of my mind and I need to-- like, we have to deal with it, you know? Why run? Why lie? Why try to cover it up then?
那么为什么在那个时候，如果你在吃药，为什么不立刻去警察局说，我做了这件可怕的事。我当时失去了理智，我需要——我们必须处理它，你知道？为什么要跑？为什么要撒谎？为什么要在那时候试图掩盖？
I just didn't. I guess that's what I-- I guess I what I should've done.
我只是没这么做。我想那是我——我想我应该做的事。
Prison staff at Wallens Ridge all told us the same thing, Vince is really like this. He wasn't putting it on for us. Also, he's gotten a lot worse in the last few years and months. When we saw him in prison, he spent the last 10 or 15 minutes of our meeting tearfully asking us-- especially Benjamin-- for help. He'd helped so many people as a doctor, he said. Didn't he deserve the same now? I'm begging you, he said.
沃伦斯岭的监狱工作人员告诉我们相同的事情，文斯确实就是这样。他不是在我们面前演戏。而且，在过去几年和几个月里他变得严重多了。当我们监狱见到他时，他在会议的最后10到15分钟里流着泪请求我们——尤其是本杰明——提供帮助。他说他作为医生帮助过那么多人。现在他不配得到同样的对待吗？我在求你，他说。
Back in the car, a little shaky after the interview, Benjamin had come to a decision.
回到车里，在采访结束后还有点发抖，本杰明做出了决定。
From our observations today, he is mentally ill. And I was trying to be discerning. I was trying to be somewhat skeptical. But I just don't think anyone could pull off what he pulled off today.
根据我们今天的观察，他患有精神疾病。我曾试图保持敏锐。我曾试图保持某种程度的怀疑。但我只是不认为任何人能在今天演出他演出的那一切。
If they weren't genuinely sick.
如果他们不是真的病了的话。
Yeah.
是的。
So we no longer think it was premeditated?
所以我们不再认为那是蓄意谋杀？
I don't think so.
我不这么认为。
OK, so we're saying we believe his story, that he snapped in the moment?
好的，所以我们是说我们相信他的故事，他在那一刻瞬间崩溃了？
That's what feels right to me. Do you feel that way, too? Because before, you were premeditation all the way.
这对我来说感觉是对的。你也有这种感觉吗？因为之前，你可是坚信这是蓄意谋杀。
I know. I guess I do feel like that. But if that's true, then he was wrongly convicted.
我知道。我想我确实有这种感觉。但如果是真的，那他就被错误定罪了。
Yep, that's right.
是的，没错。
All over again, Benjamin turned over the possible explanations for Vince's illness.
本杰明又一次推敲起文斯病情的可能解释。
I mean, I've reviewed a bunch of cases with very, I mean, uncanny similarities to this one, all related to SSRIs. He does have-- like, there's evidence to suggest that what he's saying could possibly really be true, you know?
我是说，我已经审查了一堆案件，与这个案件有非常——我是说，诡异的相似之处，都与SSRIs有关。他确实有——有证据表明他所说的话确实可能是真的，你知道吗？
And so, what do you do with that information?
那么你打算拿这些信息怎么办？
I don't know. I mean, I-- so I've wondered, obviously, what is my purpose for this? Is it my duty to do something?
我不知道。我是说，我——所以我一直想，显然，我做这些是为了什么？我是否有义务做点什么？
He directly asked you not a half hour ago. Help me. You can help me, help me.
他半小时前直接求过你。救救我。你能救我，救救我。
So now I'm left with what to do with this. I don't know what I'm going to do with this.
所以现在我得考虑怎么处理这件事了。我不知道我会怎么做。
Three weeks later, Benjamin was back at Wallens Ridge. This time, he brought along his friend Steve Buie, a psychiatrist. They talked to Vince for an hour. But when they were done, Dr. Buie wasn't sold on Benjamin's favorite hypothesis. Dr. Buie has seen a lot of people go through SSRI withdrawal, he said.
三周后，本杰明回到了沃伦斯岭。这次，他带来了他的朋友、精神科医生史蒂夫·布伊（Steve Buie）。他们和文斯谈了一个小时。但当他们谈完后，布伊医生对本杰明最喜欢的假设并不买账。布伊医生说，他见过很多人经历SSRI戒断。
But whatever was going on with Vince, it didn't seem like that. And ditto traumatic brain injury. Those don't usually cause the kind of deterioration Vince was experiencing. Then, as they were leaving the visitor's room, walking between the series of locked metal doors and barbed wire fencing, Dr. Buie stopped in his tracks.
但无论文斯身上发生了什么，看起来都不像那样。脑外伤也一样。那些通常不会导致文斯所经历的那种恶化。然后，当他们离开探视室，走在锁着的金属门和带刺铁丝网之间时，布伊医生停下了脚步。
I turned to Benjamin and just raised the question. I said, could this be Huntington's? And he sort of looked at me with a surprised expression and sort of nodded his head that yeah, it might be.
我转向本杰明，提出了这个问题。我说，这会不会是亨廷顿氏病（Huntington's）？他带着惊讶的表情看着我，并点了点头，说是的，有可能。
Huntington's disease is a horrible condition, one of the worst, like a cruel trifecta of Alzheimer's, Parkinson's, and Lou Gehrig's disease rolled into one. It causes severe emotional and physical symptoms. It's progressive, it's painful, and highly inheritable. If your parent has it, you've got a 50/50 chance of getting it. According to descriptions of Vince's father's mental and physical state, it's conceivable that's what Dalton Gilmer had.
亨廷顿氏病是一种可怕的疾病，最严重的疾病之一，就像阿尔茨海默病、帕金森病和卢·格里克病（ALS）三者合一的残酷组合。它会导致严重的心理和生理症状。它是渐进的、痛苦的且高度遗传的。如果你的父母患有此病，你有50%的概率遗传。根据对文斯父亲的精神和生理状态的描述，道尔顿·吉尔默患有亨廷顿氏病是可以想象的。
Typically, it starts to affect a person between the ages of 35 and 45. Vince's behavior began to change when he was about 40. And it's fatal. Once you have symptoms, the brain and body dwindle away. You usually die after about 20 years from a complication like pneumonia or choking. Dr. Buie and Benjamin went down a checklist of symptoms.
通常它在35到45岁之间开始影响人。文斯的行为在大约40岁时开始改变。这是致命的。一旦出现症状，大脑和身体就会逐渐衰竭。通常在约20年后因肺炎或窒息等并发症而死亡。布伊医生和本杰明列出了一份症状清单。
Behavioral disturbances.
行为障碍。
Yeah, he murdered his father.
是的，他杀了他父亲。
Hallucinations.
幻觉。
He's having-- he's hearing voices in his head.
他有——他脑子里能听到声音。
Irritability?
易怒？
He's continuing to attack other inmates, in spite of the consequences of being beat up afterwards.
他继续攻击其他犯人，尽管面临事后被暴打的后果。
Moodiness.
情绪化。
Moodiness, check. Restlessness or fidgeting, check. Paranoia, psychosis, abnormal and unusual movements, including facial movements, grimacing, quick sudden jerking movements, unsteady gait, disorientation or confusion, loss of judgment, loss of memory, personality changes, speech changes, anxiety and stress. Check, check, check, check, check, all the way down the list.
情绪化，勾选。焦躁不安或局促不安，勾选。偏执、精神病、异常和不寻常的动作，包括面部动作、做鬼脸、快速突然的抽动、步态不稳、迷失方向或困惑、判断力丧失、记忆力丧失、人格改变、言语改变、焦虑和压力。全中，全部符合。
Of course, the best way to tell is a genetic test, but none of us is a lawyer. We're not related to Vince. We have no standing with the Virginia Department of Corrections. So we weren't sure how to go about getting a test done. Then, three weeks later, on March 11, I found out from the DOC-- just by accident-- that Vince had been moved from Wallens Ridge to a psychiatric hospital within the prison system called Marion Correctional Treatment Center.
当然，判断最好的方法是基因测试，但我们都不是律师。我们和文斯没亲戚关系。我们在弗吉尼亚州惩教署没有任何身份。所以我们不知道怎么去安排测试。然后，三周后的3月11日，我从惩教署意外得知，文斯已经从沃伦斯岭被转移到监狱系统内的一家叫马里昂惩教治疗中心（Marion Correctional Treatment Center）的精神病院。
A few calls later, I was speaking to a social worker there who eventually told me Vince had threatened suicide. They'd found a couple of razor blades in his room. This social worker asked me what Benjamin and I thought of Vince's condition. I told her Benjamin actually had an idea, Huntington's.
打了几个电话后，我与那里的一位社会工作者交谈，她最终告诉我文斯曾威胁自杀。他们在他的房间里发现了两片剃须刀片。这位社会工作者问我和本杰明怎么看文斯的病情。我告诉她本杰明其实有个想法，亨廷顿氏病。
Oh, she said. Interesting. We can test for that. The next day a psychiatrist at Marion met with Vince. A psychiatrist called Benjamin. And within a week, they'd drawn blood for the Huntington's test, and sent it off to a lab in Utah.
哦，她说。有趣。我们可以检测那个。第二天，马里昂的一位精神科医生见到了文斯。一位精神科医生给本杰明打了电话。一周之内，他们抽了血进行亨廷顿氏病测试，并送往犹他州的一家实验室。
It is the 28th of March. And it's 7:30 in the morning. I just got to the clinic.
今天是3月28日。早上7:30。我刚到诊所。
Benjamin recorded this on his own.
本杰明自己记录了这段话。
And I opened the email. And the first line was, Vince Gilmer is positive for Huntington's. Allele number one sent 43 repeat CAGs, which means strongly positive. So we found it. We found an answer.
我打开了电子邮件。第一行写着，文斯·吉尔默的亨廷顿氏病检测呈阳性。等位基因编号1含有43个CAG重复序列，意味着强阳性。所以我们找到了。我们找到了答案。
I'm really excited and very sad at the same time. This is a terrifying diagnosis for Vince. I'm not sure what's worse, life in prison or dying prematurely and painfully from this disease. But we will see. I cannot believe it.
我既兴奋又非常难过。这对文斯来说是一个可怕的诊断。我不确定终身监禁还是因为这种疾病过早且痛苦地死去哪个更糟糕。但我们会看看。我无法相信。
Benjamin got this news from Vince's new psychiatrist, Dr. Colin Angliker. He's medical director and chief psychiatrist at the Marion Correctional Treatment Center. He's been a prison doctor for 25 years, which you think would make him a company man. But he's just the opposite, meaning he is the perfect doctor for Vince. He's one of those guys who enjoys proving the system wrong.
本杰明从文斯的新精神科医生科林·安格利克（Colin Angliker）医生那里得到了这个消息。他是马里昂惩教治疗中心的医疗主任和首席精神科医生。他当了25年的监狱医生，你可能会觉得他是个“体制内的人”。但他正好相反，这意味着他是文斯的完美医生。他是那种喜欢证明体制错误的人之一。
Whenever I hear somebody is very much of a malingerer, I think, uh-uh. He ain't malingering. There's something else going on.
每当我听说某人装病严重时，我想，嗯——嗯。他没装病。有其他事情发生。
Benjamin and I went to meet Dr. Angliker in Virginia last week, and he described what happened when Vince got the news.
本杰明和我上周去弗吉尼亚州见了安格利克医生，他描述了文斯得知消息时的情景。
I was kind of nervous, you know? Because it's more or less like a death sentence that you're telling somebody. But much to my surprise and personal relief, he-- so far-- has taken it very well.
我当时有点紧张，你知道吗？因为这或多或少像是对他人的死刑判决。但令我惊讶和个人宽慰的是，他——到目前为止——接受得非常好。
Why do you think that is?
你觉得为什么会这样？
Well, I think he had been trying to prove a point for some considerable time that there was something wrong with him. And nobody was paying any attention. They thought that, oh, it's all fake and he's putting it on. And that wasn't the case, isn't the case.
嗯，我想他相当长一段时间都在试图证明他身上确实有毛病。但没人注意。他们认为，哦，那全是装的，他在演戏。但事实并非如此，现在也不是。
Dr. Angliker says that since he put Vince on medication, he's feeling much better. He's walking better, talking better. He's less anxious. What medication, you ask? 80 milligrams of Celexa, uncrushed. What Vince has been asking for all along. Because it turns out Huntington's kills off brain cells, neurons which decrease production of neurotransmitters.
安格利克医生说，自从他给文斯用药后，他感觉好多了。走路更顺，说话更好。没那么焦虑了。你说用了什么药？80毫克未磨碎的西普兰。正是文斯一直要求的。因为事实证明，亨廷顿氏病会杀死脑细胞，即减少神经递质产生的神经元。
So all this time, it's possible Vince did have a serotonin-deprived brain. It's possible he was right. All this makes you wonder, to be blunt, what the hell? Benjamin asked Dr. Angliker as respectful as he could, why did this take so long?
所以这段时间，文斯的大脑可能确实缺乏血清素。他可能是对的。这一切让你不禁要问，说得直白点，到底是怎么回事？本杰明尽可能恭敬地问安格利克医生，为什么花了这么长时间？
To me, what's been so difficult to understand is that for nine years-- I mean, I'm a doctor. I'm not a psychiatrist. But after two visits with him, it was clear that he had a neurologic illness. There's obviously something going on. So it's very hard for me to appreciate that that could have been missed after numerous, numerous evaluations.
对我来说，最难理解的是这九年来——我的意思是，我是医生。我不是精神科医生。但与他见过两次之后，很明显他患有神经系统疾病。肯定发生了什么事情。所以，在经过无数次评估后居然没发现这一点，这让我很难理解。
Well, we're supposed to listen. And I have found so often that people don't listen to what patients are saying. They don't. They have a preconceived idea as to what's going on, and that's it. They are as inflexible sometimes as the system in which they find work. They have a stereotype of what an inmate is. And they won't budge beyond that.
嗯，我们本该倾听的。我经常发现人们不倾听病人在说什么。他们不听。他们对正在发生的事情有先入为主的看法，就是这样。他们有时和他们工作的体制一样缺乏灵活性。他们对犯人是什么样有成见。而且他们不会超越那个成见。
Do you think that's what happened in Vince's case?
你认为文斯的案件就是这样吗？
I'm afraid so. It was really horrendous. It just blows my mind how things went for him. And it's really sad.
恐怕是的。这真的很可怕。他所经历的一切简直让我难以置信。这真的很令人难过。
From what Dr. Angliker can tell, Vince was having psychiatric symptoms from Huntington's at the time of the killing. That's not to say Huntington's caused him to kill his father. It's not like Huntington's creates murderers. But Huntington's can cause erratic, agitated, and sometimes uncontrollable behavior. So, it's fair to say that Vince was not himself when he strangled his father. And he never should have represented himself in court.
根据安格利克医生的判断，文斯在杀人时就有亨廷顿氏病的精神症状。这并不是说亨廷顿氏病导致他杀害父亲。并不是亨廷顿氏病制造了杀人犯。但亨廷顿氏病会导致不规律、躁动且有时无法控制的行为。所以，可以公正地说，文斯在勒死父亲时已经失去了自我。他本不应该在法庭上为自己辩护。
I mean, to me, it was a travesty. He should never be in a prison. But that's me.
我的意思是，对我来说，这是一种嘲弄。他不应该在监狱里。但这是我的观点。
Of course, Dr. Angliker isn't a lawyer. So we asked one, Richard Bonnie, a professor at the University of Virginia School of Law and director of the Institute of Law, Psychiatry, and Public Policy. He says Vince's best shot might be for a lawyer to argue, probably in federal court, that Vince wasn't competent to represent himself at his trial, that he shouldn't have been allowed to do so.
当然，安格利克医生不是律师。所以我们问了一位律师，理查德·邦尼（Richard Bonnie），弗吉尼亚大学法学院教授，法律、精神病学和公共政策研究所主任。他说文斯最好的机会可能是由律师辩护，可能是在联邦法院，文斯在审判时没有能力代表自己，他不应该被允许这样做。
But really, Vince might be better off bypassing the courts and just trying to get what they call compassionate release. That is, if someone can pull the right strings in government. We hadn't spoken to Vince since January. He'd been in solitary on suicide watch at the Marion Hospital until last week.
但实际上，文斯绕过法院直接申请所谓的“同情释放”可能会更好。那就是，如果有人能触动政府的正确杠杆。我们自一月份以来就没和文斯谈过。直到上周，他一直被关在马里昂医院的自杀观察室里单独监禁。
Finally, on Monday, we were able to arrange a phone call, our first contact with him since the diagnosis. It was shocking.
最终，周一，我们成功安排了一通电话，这是自诊断以来我们与他的首次接触。这令人震惊。
Hello, Benjamin.
你好，本杰明。
How are you?
你好吗？
I am, wow, ridiculously doing so much better, it's not even funny.
我，哇，好得简直离谱，这甚至都不好笑了。
You sound so different.
你听起来真不一样。
I really and truly-- I mean, right now I'm so close to being back to normal. It's just--
我真的，真的——我是说，我现在非常接近恢复正常了。这简直是——
So glad to hear that.
很高兴听到这个。
It's just-- my brain's getting better.
简直是——我的大脑正在好转。
Vince was laughing. When we met him back at the prison three months earlier, that Vince? It didn't even occur to me that he could laugh.
文斯在笑。当我们在三个月前回到监狱见到他时，那个文斯？我甚至没想过他还能笑。
[LAUGHING] Yes, after all these years of hell and, yeah, having the DNA diagnosis that can't be argued with. And the fact that this treatment is working so well, it's just-- it's a miracle all the way around. And it's going to work out for the best.
[笑声] 是的，经历了这么多年的地狱之后，有了无法争辩的DNA诊断。而且治疗效果如此之好，简直是——这简直是个奇迹。一切都会向好的方向发展。
I know the diagnosis is terrifying.
我知道这个诊断很可怕。
For me, I'm not terrified about it. To me, it was so relieved.
对我来说，我不觉得可怕。相反，我感到非常释怀。
After about a half hour of hearing how happy he was, how hopeful, it dawned on us. Vince doesn't know anything about Huntington's. We weren't prepared for that, since Vince is a doctor. But he doesn't know what's going to happen to him, and maybe to his sister and to her two kids, and to her three grandkids. Because they're all at risk for Huntington's now. So Benjamin did the hardest thing in the world. He told him. Vince's response was pragmatic.
听了他半小时的讲述他是多么开心、多么充满希望，我们突然意识到。文斯对亨廷顿氏病一无所知。我们对此毫无准备，因为文斯是医生。但他不知道将来会发生什么，也许他的妹妹、她的两个孩子，还有她的三个孙辈也可能会遭殃。因为他们现在都有遗传亨廷顿氏病的风险。所以本杰明做了世界上最艰难的事。他告诉了他。文斯的反应是务实的。
I mean, right now, there isn't-- what is the treatment now?
我是说，现在，没有——现在的治疗方案是什么？
Just symptomatic treatment. There's no-- nothing at this point that can reverse the process, unfortunately.
只是对症治疗。没有——目前还没有任何东西能逆转这个过程，遗憾的是。
Right.
明白。
They talked for an hour. And Vince didn't seem defeated at all by this terrible news. For now, he's just so glad to be getting the Celexa, surrounded by people who believe what he says to them. By the end, Benjamin and Vince were just two doctors, talking about the Cane Creek clinic. Benjamin told him how his patients and friends were taking the news. Vince remembered working there, hanging out with the staff. How if they got paid in corn, they'd heat it in the microwave and dip it in butter. And how he missed working with the patients.
他们谈了一个小时。文斯看起来一点也没被这个可怕的消息击垮。目前，他只是因为能得到西普兰（Celexa）而感到高兴，周围的人都相信他所说的话。最后，本杰明和文斯只是两名医生，讨论着甘蔗溪诊所。本杰明告诉他病人和朋友们是如何接受这个消息的。文斯回想起在那里工作的情景，和员工们呆在一起。如果他们用玉米当报酬，他们会用微波炉加热，蘸着黄油吃。以及他是多么怀念与病人一起工作的日子。
It was such a-- what's the word for it-- a blessing, to be able to actually be there and share those people's lives.
那真是——怎么说呢——一种祝福，能够真地在那里并分享那些人的生活。
I'm sorry if you feel like the medical community turned their back on you.
如果医疗界背弃了你，我很抱歉。
You didn't turn your backs on me. You did not. You came all the way across the mountains and came to see me in the prison. Because all those patients, patients that you took care of, that you take care of, they kept telling you, no. That's not him. And you're right. That's not who I am. And I'm becoming who I am again. And, um, thank you.
你们没有背弃我。你们没有。你们跨越了群山，到监狱里来看我。因为所有那些病人，你照顾的病人，你所照顾的那些人，他们一直告诉你，不。那不是他。你是对的。那不是我是谁。我正在重新成为我自己。而且，嗯，谢谢。
Benjamin started out as Vince's freaked out replacement, but over the course of seven months, he'd become Vince's detective. And then, his physician, the physician Vince never had. Now, Benjamin wants to become his lawyer. He wants to get Vince out.
本杰明最初是作为文斯那个吓坏了的接替者出现的，但在七个月的时间里，他成了文斯的侦探。然后，成了他的医生，那个文斯从未拥有过的医生。现在，本杰明想成为他的律师。他想救文斯出去。
Sarah Koenig is one of the producers of our show.
莎拉·柯尼格是我们节目的制片人之一。
[MUSIC -"Call the Doctor," J.J. Cale]
[音乐 - “Call the Doctor,” J.J. Cale]
Our program was produced today by Miki Meek and myself with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer for today's show is Julie Snyder. Production help today from Anna Martin. Mixing by Stowe Nelson and our Technical director, Matt Tierney. Music help for today's show from Damien Graef, from Rob Geddes.
我们今天的节目由我与米基·米克（Miki Meek）制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、莎拉·柯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）。今天节目的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。今天的制作协助来自安娜·马丁（Anna Martin）。混音由斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）完成，技术总监是马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）。今天节目的音乐协助来自达米安·格拉夫（Damien Graef）和罗伯·格迪斯（Rob Geddes）。
Special thanks today to Jonathan Milner, Larry Traylor at the Virginia Department of Corrections, Rebecca Young at the Wallens Ridge State Prison, Wayne Austin, Gloria Hitt, Fred Taubman at the Huntington's Disease Society of America, Deirdre Smith-Gilmer, Leona McKinney, Jay Leutze, Michelle Harris, Erin Brethauer, Jamie Nicholson, Johnny Irion, Sarah Lee Guthrie, Lou Teti, Frances Walker, Bulldog Studios in Sag Harbor, and all the staff at MAHEC Cane Creek.
特别感谢乔纳森·米尔纳（Jonathan Milner）、弗吉尼亚州惩教署的拉里·特雷勒（Larry Traylor）、沃伦斯岭州立监狱的丽贝卡·杨（Rebecca Young）、韦恩·奥斯汀（Wayne Austin）、格洛丽亚·希特（Gloria Hitt）、美国亨廷顿氏病协会的弗雷德·陶布曼（Fred Taubman）、迪尔德丽·史密斯-吉尔默（Deirdre Smith-Gilmer）、利昂娜·麦金尼（Leona McKinney）、杰·卢茨（Jay Leutze）、米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）、艾琳·布雷绍尔（Erin Brethauer）、杰米·尼科尔森（Jamie Nicholson）、约翰尼·艾里昂（Johnny Irion）、莎拉·李·格思里（Sarah Lee Guthrie）、卢·泰蒂（Lou Teti）、弗朗西斯·沃克（Frances Walker）、萨格港的斗牛犬工作室（Bulldog Studios）以及MAHEC甘蔗溪的所有员工。
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is distributed by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, I just-- by coincidence-- ran into the guy who took over when Torey stopped running his Tupperware club.
我们的网站是ThisAmericanLife.org。《This American Life》由公共广播交易所（PRX）发行。一如既往，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道，我只是——巧合地——碰到了在托里停止经营特百惠俱乐部后接手的那个人。
Yeah, I'm following the footsteps of an ax murderer.
是的，我是在追随一个斧头杀手的脚步。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories on This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到这里，带来更多《This American Life》的故事。